nouveau aujourd'hui on se lance dans le
cinéma tu vas fait des petites emplettes
très sympa avec ça un clap a commencé
toutes les scènes avec un clap
c'est hollywood chez monsieur monsieur
russell du cloud première aujourd'hui on
va parler d'apple parce que je suis
extrêmement déçu par apple scène de la
déception premières s'explique je suis
plutôt ce qu'on appelle un bon client
c'est à dire que si apple fait quelques
années que je suis équipé en afrique un
ibook g4
ça c'est ce qu'on appelle un macbook pro
c'est ce que j'utilise en ce moment ça
c'est mal l'ipad une bonne taille fixe s
watch un iphone 4 qui d'ailleurs s'est
arrêtée tout seul un 3gs 6 sg-1 5 cm et
c'est justin qui l'a donc qu'il est pas
là mais le problème avec tout ça c'est
que ça c'est le cas de l'adaptateur si
tu veux te permet de brancher le pack
book pro au secteur est d'abord de la
recharge
sauf que cette jolie petite chose si tu
le vois bien là et complètement éclaté
donc du coup cette simple et achètent ça
en gros si tu veux mon macbook pro je
vais l'acheter en 2011 et tous les deux
ans j'ai ça qui pète qui est fragile
alors je suis pas un sauvage je fais pas
n'importe quoi
je prends pas mes affaires et
jette pas partout je n'ai pas n'importe
quoi et ce qui m'emmerde réellement si
tu veux c'est que ce truc là je trouve
que c'est quand même fragile
donc j'ai appelé apple pour leur dire
bon apple
là on est en 2017 je l'échangé en 2015
et je l'avais déjà changé en 2013 cogis
pas de conneries qu'ils essayent
d'origine donc si tu veux quand tu
achètes ce truc là il ya deux ans je les
payais 69 euros pour recharger et là je
les payais 90 euros 89 euros 90 euros
t'imagines juste hyper cher j'appelle
apple on leur explique en voilà je suis
hyper embêté parce que ça je pense qu'il
ya quand même c'est un produit qui est
fragile et qui a extrêmement cher je
pense que je suis plutôt un bon client
donc est ce que vous pensez qu'il serait
possible d'avoir un geste commercial
dessus alors je me doutais que non je me
suis éclaté apple n'a pas y avait bien
sûr regardé mais bien sûr vous êtes à
mon client je n'avais léger pour 4000
5000 euros chez nous bien sûr vous êtes
un bon client pour faire un geste
commercial pour l'adaptateur qui vous
coûte 90 euros non mais c'est pas ça qui
m'embête parce qu'à la limite on a droit
de me dire non et apple comme dire non
voilà à écouter on pense que le produit
vous l'utilisez mal vous l'avait abîmée
ça je peux complètement le comprendre
mais par contre ce que j'ai du mal à
comprendre c'est que je contacter apple
le jeudi 6 avril 2017
j'ai quand un quentin qui est d'ailleurs
plutôt sympa hein
quant à lille qui on discute j'explique
d'un problématique et que j'explique que
les produits sont chers et quentin il me
renvoie vers marion parce qu'il me dit
moi je peux rien faire pour vous voyez
match est fini par avoir marion et on
m'explique qu'il ya un problème de
logiciel chez apple ce que je peux
complètement comprendre et qu'on va me
recontacter très rapidement soit dans la
journée soit demain matin donc on est le
jeudi 6 je me dis que le vendredi 7 au
matin ou dans la journée
genre un petit coup de fil de mario qui
va pouvoir dire non parce que je me
doutais que certaines - dirais non on
est aujourd'hui le mardi 11 avril 2017
je n'ai pas eu un seul coup de fil de
personnes chez apple alors qu'il s'était
engagé à me rappeler et c'est ça qui me
pose problème parce que en réalité toi
tes clients
tu clak beaucoup d'oser parce que tu
aimes les produits thème l'environnement
et puis moi je trouve ça relativement
sympa mais ça me pose problème ça ça
pose réellement problème quand j'ai eu
ce fameux grand temps au téléphone jeudi
quentin c'est cher quant à ses chers ces
90 07
donc moi je veux bien passer les
produits chers je suis hélas pour les
acheter donc quelque part c'est qu'il me
demande et s'il ya des comme moi tant
mieux
mais qu'est ce que me dit quand tu as en
face et me oui mais vous comprenez c'est
cher mais de l'autre côté il ya une
qualité et plier un service regarder
tout de suite je suis au téléphone je
suis aimable janvier dernier ainsi que
quand même pas m'engueuler je suis
aimable je vous réponds et je vous
apporte des solutions sauf que là il est
très clair que le sav d'apple a pris un
engagement c'est l'engagement de me
rappeler et que personne n'a rappelé et
je sais très bien qu'au jour
d'aujourd'hui personne l'on rappellera
donc là j'aimerais qu'on explique bien
si jamais thing ou que vous regardez
cette vidéo ce que je ne pense pas mais
en tout cas c'est quelqu'un chez apple
regarde cette vidéo il faudra
m'expliquer quand on se dit premium
il faut l'être jusqu'au bout pourquoi
est-ce que vous ne rappelait pas vos
clients quel qu'il soit qu'il achète un
petit produit
un petit produit coûte toujours cher les
petits produits quels que soient clients
qu'il a pour plusieurs milliers d'euros
chez vous ou qui lèche quelques
centaines d'euros chez vous quand on
s'engage à rappeler on rappelle ça c'est
pas acceptable
et ça c'est un très très gros carton
rouge à apple moi je pensais dans
quelques temps pouvoir switcher
peut-être sur l'iphone bid j'attends
vraiment de voir les nouveautés et de
voir ce qui va être annoncé et l'art en
tout cas je suis extrêmement déçu est
vraiment là pour le coup je trouve que
vous êtes pas du tout à la hauteur en
termes de gestion de l savez quand on
dit qu'on rappelle un client au rappel
un point c'est tout
[Musique]
aussi penser à mettre à jour cet
ordinateur on va chercher du matos
[Musique]
oui
c
terre
pas les macbook pro 2011 sont super le
gros problème avec si tu veux c'est
qu'arrivé à un moment ça rame c'est
incroyable quand tu fais du montage
vidéo souvent eu quelques pros c'est
insupportable là j'ai changé mon disque
dur j'ai mis un ssd ça marche très très
bien comme ça maintenant j'ai pas notre
investissement
j'ai acheté de la mémoire vive de
crucial est normalement pour la vidéo ça
ira beaucoup mieux ça marche
bon sinon c'est pas entendu depuis la
semaine dernière et c'est vrai que là le
week-end a été juste génial j'ai marié
meilleur ami leonard
on a passé un super moment une super
journée et le soir on était très fatigué
donc là la semaine commence t va y avoir
plein plein de nouveautés début de
semaine prochaine je te créer un
événement je vais finalisé pour faire
gagner le jeu je te ferai mais vonn qui
en fera gagner want to switch fait un
petit moment que le concours dure
d'ailleurs tu peux aller voir tout cas
encore s'inscrire au concours a tout de
suite maintenant si tu veux là haut
le concours est encore en ligne tu peux
encore jouer pour gagner ta copine de
wons 206 a aucun problème on fera des
vagues la semaine prochaine on fera un
direct indirect sur youtube directement
pour pouvoir discuter
moi je prendrais le temps de regarder un
peu les différents commentaires voir un
peu ce qui s'est passé et puis en direct
qui a gagné à ce moment là le jeu one to
switch que je vous enverrai en sachant
que c'est ma copine donc c'est mon jeu
c'est moi qui l'a achetée c'est plein de
sponsoriser par personne d'ailleurs je
tiens juste à préciser parce que c'est
vrai que j'ai beaucoup de deux messages
par rapport aux vidéos que j'ai fait sur
l'iphone ou alors sur le samsung le
galaxy et suite je tiens à préciser que
je suis pas du tout sponsorisé pour
faire cette vidéo sur mon avis un avis
qui est très personnel le site est sorti
mais je n'ai pas eu entre les mains donc
je peux pas faire de review technique
juste en parler et dire ce que si ça me
blesse et ça me plaît pas je tenais à
faire ce petit poids parce que je vois
qu effectivement ça peut des fois gêner
certaines personnes je suis pas parti
prenant effectivement je suis client
chez apple mais à mon avis ça risque de
ne pas durer
super longtemps toujours est il que
voilà j'aime bien donner mon point de
vue en disant j'aime ce produit je
n'aime pas voici pourquoi comment après
quand j'aurai produit quand je pourrai
testant lui-même à ce moment là on
pourra en discuter et je pose en lire
davantage par rapport au ressenti mais
bon en tout cas pour l'instant je veux
plus du concept que du produit en
lui-même ferme la parenthèse dont one to
switch et gagne
le week-end était super j'espère que toi
aussi tu vas bien t'as pas sans aucune
il va y avoir pas mal de nouveautés dans
les temps à venir
j'étais garde encore une petite surprise
je te dirai ça d'ici quelques jours
d'ici quelques jours aussi on va faire
le tirage au sort du concours pour le
parfum diesel bad donc ne t'inquiète pas
si tu as participé
d'ici quelques jours on saura qui sera
le gagnant ou la gagnante de ce partage
a pris un petit peu de temps mais je
vais m'y coller c'est promis il ya plein
de choses plein de nouveautés qui
arrivent je te remercie d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo
j'espère a pas avoir trop râler contre
apple mail a fondamentalement je suis
extrêmement en colère et j'estime que
ils sont absolument pas à la hauteur
merci d'avoir regardé la vidéo
à très bientôt et d'ici là pour porte
toi bien ciao